Stephen King's The Dark Tower has
finally arrived in theaters after a long
and complicated journey to the big
screen
however Hollywood's latest attempt to
launch a cinematic universe didn't
exactly go as planned the movie was
widely panned by critics and open to a
disappointing nineteen point five
million dollar haul this was still good
enough for first place but the movies
lackluster performance with critics and
audiences can only be seen as a
disappointment for both the studio as
well as for King fans who waited years
to see the books brought to life here's
what went wrong with the dark towers
big-screen debut and a friendly warning
spoilers for both the movies and the
books lie ahead source material miss
Reed the many many stories King penned
in The Dark Tower universe spanned quite
a lot of plot but the studio decided to
mix and match elements from all of them
which still wind up being a sequel to
the books rather than an adaptation so
we actually tried we actually took the
world and sort of sticks it a little bit
together without sort of losing the the
promise of greater adventure the
groundwork was laid at the end of the
seventh book of Kings Agra when our hero
Roland is chained finally reaches the
top of the dark tower and realizes he'd
been on this long journey many times
before while picking the movie up with
the final book leaves off may have
seemed like a smart way for the
filmmakers to boil down the novel's epic
scale into just one film it was also
alienating to the hardcore fans we've
been hoping to see the actual events of
the novel's themselves play out on
screen the dark tower also straddled the
difficult line of trying to appeal to
those who hadn't read any of the books
and those who'd read every word that
effort to please fans and make the
content digestible enough for new
audiences simply didn't work adding up
to a movie that didn't give anyone what
they were looking for while the movie
did a fair job of setting up at central
quest story it failed to sell the deeper
conflicts inherent in the epic journey
of the characters and felt incomplete
speaking of which run time run nowadays
viewers who walk into big budget
blockbusters expect to be in the
theaters for at least two hours and
often more The Dark Tower easily could
have filled up this runtime in fact it
probably would have helped it's awkward
attempt to fit so many disparate
elements from kings novels into one
movie
I'm uestion alone in the library a lot
director Nick our cell however decided
to instead keep the film in a very tight
ninety five minutes the director said he
did this because he saw the film as an
introduction to the world of the novel's
adding that the movie had a lean script
that would introduce the basic ideas of
the project without being too
overwhelming at first
while this runtime may have been doable
had our cell chosen to only focus on the
first book the movies decision to mix
and match elements from all of Kings
books is a pseudo sequel meant it had to
introduce huge amounts of information
while playing out its story although
ourself saw the short run time as a way
to build the world without doing too
much
some sod is being too brief leaving the
world feeling empty and unfinished the
movie could have benefited from an extra
30 minutes of world-building if not more
filmmaking fracas our cell wasn't the
first director to try his hand in
adapting the dark hour in 2007 JJ Abrams
pulled together his lost pals Carlton
Cuse and Damon Lindelof who were also
big fans of Stephen King but they ended
up letting go the adaptation option
because they were too nervous about
messing up the love at work
that's when Ron Howard stepped up to the
plate with a plan for three movies and a
TV series to bring the story to life the
project was set up at Universal Pictures
but the studio pulled the plug on that
expensive idea and it took three more
years for the movie rights to find
another home with media rights capital
and Sony Pictures but that wasn't the
end of the behind-the-scenes drama MRC
and Sony were reportedly unhappy with an
early cut of the film and considered
bringing in a more experienced director
to do another cut that cost would have
been too high though
so they shelled out funding for reshoots
amid creative collisions all that
infighting led to the release date being
pushed back a whopping three times which
probably tipped fans off to how troubled
this production was the tower will fall
bad buzz whether it was a result of
behind the scenes turmoil or just a
strategy advertising for The Dark Tower
ended up being rather minimal the first
trailer didn't arrive until early May
three months before the film's release
and was overshadowed by other more
high-profile genre movies by being
stingy with promotional materials the
studio may have been trying to avoid
oversaturation that plan clearly
backfired two weeks before its release
had failed to even track in the top ten
movies being talked about on social
media despite a largely ignored video
game offering and the only thing that
really got
talking was when critics completely
eviscerated the movie it's debatable how
much influence bad reviews actually have
an audience's but the fact that this
film is dangerously close to a one-digit
Rotten Tomatoes rating probably didn't
encourage people who are on the fence
about seeing the pic to buy a ticket
turning the TV the dark hour may have
been a box office disappointment but
Sony and MRC still seem to be moving
ahead with at least one aspect of the
franchise well there's no word yet on
whether the plan movie sequels will move
forward the TV show made a major step
just before the film was released by
adding The Walking Dead's Glen Mazzara
as a showrunner the TV series is said to
be a prequel to the books focusing on
king's wizard and glass now while that
means it will likely have a different
field in the films it'll see the return
of Idris Elba's Roland Tom Taylor's Jake
and others it's still very early in that
process but the hiring of Mazzara hints
that it could be getting off the ground
soon the group is hoping to begin
production in 2018 so it looks like The
Dark Tower hasn't fallen just yet you
are in very bad shape I dream in
Cynthiana I'm stronger than most thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]